[Applaudissements]
être humain n'est pas sans faille où
qu'ils aillent est pourtant l'une
flammes mais quelquefois des rails
la souffrance est partout tout autour
que nous à bagages
elle nous touche tous ceux que l'on soit
à cause des combats ce sans tabou quand
le mot bien-être est devenu trop tabou
accepté de dire qu'elle fait partie de
nous mais que nous soyons assez malin
pour en venir à bout
nous avons tous un point commun vous et
moi qui n'a jamais souffert ici
voyez cette
là c'est une femme lotus vous savez pour
cette fleur parce que pour devenir aussi
belle à les besoins de la boue sans boue
n'y aurait pas eu de fleurs j'aime cette
faire parce qu'elle représente
l'expérience de ma vie je pense qu'étant
plus jeune je rêvais de l'incarner mais
j'ignorais géniaux aussi qu'un jour
cette fleur ferait partie intégrante de
ma vie c'est quand vous avez souffert
pour la dernière fois il ya un an un
mois quelques jours quelques heures
pourtant parce que personne même
souffrir n'est ce pas au fond nous
désirons tous vous et moi dit dans la
joie et la bonne humeur avec la paix
autour de nous oui ou non
mais pourquoi donc à l'air de
l'intelligence artificielle
cela est encore si difficile à appliquer
pour beaucoup d'entre nous l'être humain
était capable de sortir de sa caverne
pour aller jusqu à marcher sur la lune
mais nous sommes pour la plupart
incapables de cultiver notre paix
intérieure en toutes circonstances c'est
quand même fou nos accords un mot de
vote première souffrance le tout premier
valette de votre vie en y réfléchissant
bien j'en ai déduit qu'elle a débuté de
notre entrée dans ce monde terrestre
en effet je m'en souviens plus mais
j'imagine que sortir des lieux plutôt
confortable nous avions tous nos besoins
nourrit en permanence à un monde pour y
arriver il faut passer par un orifice de
10 cm alors vous en mesurer entre 30 et
50 et pezi rendu à 4 kilos et je me dis
qu'il aurait pu mieux faire comme
passager arrivé sur terre n'est ce pas
arriver dehors à froid t'as faim tu as
le mouillé ça pue tu es obligé de crier
pleurer pour exprimer ses doutes a
besoin là tout de suite en fait c'est la
grosse galère pour notre mère ce n'est
pas une partie de plaisir non plus n
était pas la dir weh masip tivio tous
avec un verre de champagne à la main et
la musique à fond
non boston n'est ce pas mesdames assuré
moi nous pouvons donc dire que nous
sommes tous nés avec un éminent un
minimum de souffrance
nous sommes des temps et grâce à la
souffrance c'est un fait la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on sent
artix nous sommes donc tous des
survivants c'était difficile mais pas
impossible
si vous faites la liste de toutes les
difficultés
vous avez réussi à dépasser depuis votre
enfance qui vous ont aidé à grandir en
apprenant de l'expérience des vous
constaterez que cette clique
cette liste elle est super longue ça en
fait des succès au final n'est ce pas le
problème de la souffrance non pas la
souffrance en elle-même mais la façon
dont nous allons l'aborder l'accueillir
la traversée la vivre la transformer
pour qu'elle disparaisse
vous savez quoi ça tombe bien ce que
tout comme vous des problèmes dans ma
vie j'en ai eu plein j'ai grandi en
banlieue parisienne jusqu'à mes 19 ans
en france
j'étais le gars qui aimait traîner
dehors tagué volée et me laisser aller à
d'autres vices de la rue plus
inavouables à la maison j'étais
confronté à beaucoup de problèmes de
communication avec mon père
les coups de ceinture les punitions en
finir par m'endurcir et m'ont poussé
avec le temps à me rebeller à défier
l'autorité mais c'est pas vraiment ses
coûts qui montrent plus marqué le manque
de mots ancré en moi
de nombreux mots
j'émettais
la rue je me suis véritablement retrouvé
après notre dispute de trop
j'avais de la boue jusqu'au cou le
tendre âge
bach histoire d'enfoncer cloud de passer
par un foyer d'accueil
et me voilà ramené par une énergie que
je remercie chaque jour sur la terre de
mes ancêtres à l'île de la réunion
une valise à la main et plein de rêves
dans la tête
au début c'est vrai j'ai pas mal galéré
j'avais rien mis à part ma barbe et mes
cheveux longs j'ai commencé par des
petits boulots comme entre autres
nettoyer les vitres des appartements de
la fac pour me rendre compte assez
rapidement que la vue était plus jolie
de l'autre côté c'est ainsi que malgré
le peu de moyens dont je disposais que
j'ai décidé de retourner à l'école et
que j'ai enfin obtenu un bac pro avec
mention et mon bts les années suivantes
la fleur de lotus s'était remise à
pousser dans la boue il est vrai que la
vie a mis de nombreuses épreuves devant
moi mais elle m'a appris à être rackham
au film c'est à dire des brouillards
même si on n'a rien on baisse pas les
bras on cherche des plans b pour remplir
nos objectifs
c'est donc avec cet esprit que lafleur
continuer de grandir et que je me suis
retrouvé investi dans le monde
associatif
un monde totalement inconnu pour moi au
départ j'ai donc tout appris en
confrontant aux difficultés du terrain
mais j'ai compris que la persévérance et
l engrais de la fleur si on m'avait
époque que j'allais réussir à créer un
emploi dans un domaine qui me passionne
à devenir chef d'entreprise a réalisé
mes projets qu'ils soient artistiques
familiaux professionnels
franchement je vous aurais jamais cru au
vu de ce bon sur laquelle il m'arrive de
dormir quelques années plus tôt
ce chemin ma porte a donc des réussites
au delà de mes espérances mais également
des leçons il ya mes erreurs et mes
échecs il va t'on
où tout s'écroule autour de moi vous
savez sur période devant l'impression
que rien ne va plus que chaque tour
s'écroule une à une devant vous par la
famille les amis le travail le jour ça
m'arrivait la fois de trop le ras-le-bol
complet j'ai dit de m'asseoir sur
quelques vieilles couvertures dans une
petite pièce aussi sombre que mon état
d'esprit du moment
en fait je me suis souvenu d'une
position digne d'un contorsionniste pour
certains la posture du lotus
une posture qui a impliqué à être
présents corps et esprit dans le moment
et a laissé passer ses pensées me
détacher de mes pensées négatives
exactement ce dont j'avais besoin à
l'époque
sa tombe est super bien je vous invite à
fermer les yeux
faites-le vraiment fermer les yeux
quelques instants mettez vos mains sur
les genoux
voilà prenez une bonne respiration
imaginez vos pensées comme si elle était
un nuage qui traverse dans le ciel si
l'une d'elles vient vous importuner vous
arrosez ou même vous jeter ses éclairs
vous prenez une simple inspiration et
vous ramenez votre attention dans le
moment présent
pour ma part j'ai continué cette
pratique
malgré les douleurs et les tentations
d'arrêter pour y trouver un jour le
trésor du calme pendant la tempête
je venais de découvrir la méditation et
sa dimension spirituelle et c'est ainsi
que je suis devenu quelques années plus
tard
le moine bouddhiste cause animale
[Applaudissements]
j'avais enfin compris que la paix sur
terre était difficile mais pas
impossible et qu'elle commençait à
l'intérieur de nous là où se situe votre
fleur cultiver le bonheur de la paix
intérieure est un art qui se pratiquent
chaque jour sans relâche cette difficile
mais pas impossible
il est évident que savoir cultiver la
bienveillance dans son quotidien
et bien cela s'apprend ou plutôt se
réapprend en effet lorsqu'on était bébé
on était naturellement bienveillant de
nombreuses l'étude le monde comme lé
spectre bien mathieu ricard dans son
plaidoyer pour l'altruisme ce n'est
qu'en grandissant que l'enfant s'éloigne
de sa nature profonde
il expérimente quoi le mensonge
l'individualisme l'égoïsme la loi du
plus grand du plus beau du plus fort la
bienveillance alors bien du mal à
cohabiter avec tous ces aspects la
gentillesse est perçu comme une
faiblesse qu'une force alors me direz
vous comment faire pour aider nos fleurs
de bienveillance à se servir de leurs
difficultés boueuse pour grandir devenir
plus forte plus radieuse est la première
chose sur le mois et d'apprendre à
reconnaître quand elle est présente et
quand elle ne l'est pas pour cela je
vais vous proposer un petit exercice
très simple imaginez que vous venez
d'être victime d'une injustice
vous êtes arrivé ce matin vous étiez en
avant et pris votre billet mais on vous
a refusé l'entrée on a laissé passer
tout le monde soit vous essayez de vous
connecter à ce que vous pourriez
ressentir à cet instant-là fait que fait
le vraiment sincèrement
voilà maintenant on vous apprend que à
mon signal en fait vous allez regarder
la personne de gauche ou de droite tout
en sachant que c'est elle qui vous a
refusé l'entrée tout simplement parce
qu'elle vous aime pas
parce qu'elle est branchée elle a des
appuis dans l'organisation du tmx
c'est pour ça allez-y faites le vraiment
et que juste quelques instants avec le
visage de colère vraiment essayé de
transmettre votre colère
j'ai raté mon coup très bien bon je sais
que vous avez compris à moi je voulais
en venir
d'accord d'essayer de ressentir que
vraiment de cette énergie c'est pas
vraiment agréable mais que ça nous
arrive tout le temps
donc maintenant on va proposer leurs
solutions qui est plus facile je vous
invitais à sourire de manière sincère et
authentique
en fait instruire qui est connecté avec
votre coeur qui donne qui reçoit chaque
jour sans rien demander en retour
l'idée d'y mettre une attention
bienveillante allez-y maintenant lâchez
vous
comment vous sentez vous maintenant
[Rires]
voilà je vous invite à vous chrono de
vous connecter avec votre chronomètre
qui se situe au niveau de votre coeur
mettez votre main et essayé de le
ressentir quelques instants voilà il est
en route depuis le début votre création
un jour ce chronomètre s'arrêtera
certains poussent le destin le faire
avant l'heure mais d'une manière
générale on ne décide pas de la tête
d'épuisement des piles s'empilent plus
de chronomètre maintenant imaginez vous
à quelques instants de ce compte à
rebours qu'est ce que vous aimeriez voir
derrière vous à cet instant une personne
qui a su traverser les épreuves de sa
vie qui a appris à transformer ses
souffrances en sagesse ou une personne
qui a subi la souffrance toute sa vie
s'est empêtrée dedans sans en tirer
aucun enseignement
d'ailleurs on y voit avec votre flore de
bienveillance est elle bien présente
dans votre vie si tel n'est pas
totalement le cabba que pourriez vous
décidez de faire pour aider ces graines
à germer une à une en vous mais
également chez les autres pour qu'ils
puissent aussi à leur tour la cultiver
est ce que mon intervention ce sera
qu'une intervention parmi d'autres pour
vous divertir ou est-ce qu'elle
contribuera à vous encourager à passer à
l'action
on va continuer d'agir en propageant
votre paix intérieure en toutes
circonstances on ne s'inquiète
dame n'est pas d'un strip-tease je suis
pas tout nu tsoup
[Rires]
pub ça marque
une autre clé que j'ai trouvé en plus de
la pratique du sourire et de la
méditation
l utilisation bienveillant de la parole
vous l'aurez compris j'aime les mots
mais j'ai appris qu'un mot a le pouvoir
de blessés parfois de tuer mais aussi
celui de soulager guerrière redonner un
sourire
c'est pourquoi il faut les utiliser
soigneusement facile à dire mais
difficile à faire dans le feu de
l'action n'est ce pas difficile mais pas
impossible
avec quoi je vais là l'école pendant
presque vingt ans est ce qu'il ya
quelques années que j'ai appris qu'il
existait une autre façon de communiquer
eu plus respectueuse plus sereine
tu prend en compte les sentiments et les
besoins de chacun sans être forcément
dans l'exigence l'accusation la critique
jugement seule la nature a demandé mais
pourquoi on a appris cette langue quand
j'étais à l'école ça m'aurait évité
beaucoup de problèmes que j'ai
rencontrés pour aider concrètement les
gens à cultiver leur intérieur j'ai donc
décidé de créer l'académie de la
bienveillance avec mon équipe
cette structure propose des outils pour
aider le public à gérer les conflits à
mieux écouter à s'exprimer de façon
sincère et authentique à se dépasser et
également réaliser son projet de vie
nous intervenons auprès de différents
types de public avec une prédominance
pour les jeunes en galère sur les terres
arides du milieu carcéral familiales
professionnelles personnelles
en fait nous allons là où les fleurs de
lotus ont du mal à éclore dans la boue à
l'issue de leur formation
s'ils valident leurs acquis nous leur
remettant le diplôme du positif
combattants qui symbolise leur
engagement à être des artisans de la
paix au quotidien la rencontre avec ses
milliers de personnes de différents
horizons m'a fait prendre conscience
d'une chose
aucun être humain n'est vraiment mauvais
où même total même totalement bon chacun
a un vécu un caractère un
conditionnement mental
jeudi vers des expériences de sa vie il
ya des gens qui parfois tombe mais tu
vaux mieux avec les outils qu'ils ont à
l'instant t pour essayer d'être heureux
aujourd'hui une seconde chose est
certaine pour moi rien n'est figé
le criminel d'hier peut devenir un
bienfaiteur aujourd'hui s'il s'est mis
en route et a pris arroser ses bonnes
graines style une pub vous aussi vous le
pouvez la bienveillance n'est pas
réservé à une élite
elle nous concerne tous et n'est pas de
devenir parfait mais de s'améliorer un
petit peu chaque jour et de l'art
lyon peut-il française perdue dans le
second radia est pour moi une fleur de
lotus capable d'inspirer la planète à la
bienveillance tout simplement parce
qu'elles disposent déjà de ces jeunes on
l écoute fait de l'esclavagé la pauvreté
l'ont jadis fait plier mais elle a su se
relever en transformant s'étonne de
souffrance pour devenir un exemple
mondial du vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui même si tout n'est pas rose
le sourire le bonjour aux inconnus dans
la rue est toujours bien vivant bien
palpable cela fut difficile mais les
clés sont maintenant dans vos mains vous
avez le choix
vous savez maintenant qu'il est possible
et réaliste d'apprendre à cultiver la
bienveillance dans votre quotidien
en incarnant le positif combattants qui
sommeille en chacun de nous l'aurez
compris on peut être dans la rue est
bienveillant on peut et en prison être
bienveillant on peut donc être aussi
dans votre vie et pratiquer la
bienveillance et comme l'avait si bien
dit gandhi dans son tombe commencer par
changer en vous ce que vous voulez voir
changer autour de vous et incarner ce
changement c'est tout ce que je vous
souhaite
[Applaudissements]